part of this video is sponsored by data
cab
today i'd like to take a look at one
american exam the sat
it's used for college admission in the
u.s and it's been around in some form
for nearly 100 years in 2020
there were over 2.2 million students who
sat the exam
you don't need to be in america to take
it it comes with its
controversies and criticism and anything
that's sat by that many students
is bound to have a cultural impact but
the sat
isn't like the extremely hard entrance
exams that we've seen from other
countries
like india and china you don't even need
to know calculus to be able to ace the
math section
it comes with a different motive instead
of trying to rank what a student has
already learned
the sat is supposed to be designed to
assess
a student's readiness for college and it
forms
only part of a college application
alongside
personal essays references school grades
and
extracurricular activities so just out
of interest
let's have a look at it i've got here a
practice test
it takes three hours excluding an
optional essay
there's a reading and writing section
and a math section
with maths there's mostly multiple
choice
and for some questions you can't use a
calculator and some you can
so here's the math questions and they do
start off pretty easy
we have finding the value of an unknown
in a simple equation
so we've got algebra some algebra again
here
at more of a word problem and working
out a linear relationship
from this table you'll want to be
confident with
reading graphs and your algebra skills
and simplification
but all of the questions are possible to
figure out in just a few lines of
working
this question uses trigonometry you just
need to find the cosine of an
angle and know that a similar triangle
will have
similar angles there's questions about
parabolas
circles and simultaneous equations
this is the section where you're allowed
to use a calculator
but to be honest you don't need it for
most of them
for a few of them though it might help
you work out the answers sooner
but for a lot of them i feel like it
would actually slow you down
this question shows two lists of numbers
and asks
if the means are the same or different
and if the standard
deviations are the same or different i
kind of like this question because
it reminds me of this part on mario
party
where you can unlock special dice but
you have to choose whether or not you
actually want to use them
i tried the questions myself under the
time pressure
and i did get too wrong because of silly
mistakes
35 was one of the ones i got wrong
you've got
a times x plus b is equal to 4x
plus 10. it says in the equation above
a and b are constants if the equation
has
infinitely many solutions for x what is
the value of b
i left my answer as just 10 over a and
didn't realize that i could solve for a
as well the other one that i got wrong
was question 14.
the square root of 4x is equal to x
minus 3.
what are all values of x that satisfy
the given equation
is it one or is it nine or is it both or
neither
i originally wrote down the right answer
for this which was b
but then i crossed it out and wrote c
because i got bamboozled over whether or
not they were talking about the
principal route
i can claim that the questions were kind
of easy for me but
i'm really not the target audience for
this i'm older than what you would be
trying to set this which i think would
be around 17.
the reading and writing questions were i
found a bit harder because there are
some questions in here that i thought
were pretty subjective
and there's definitely no room to argue
your point when you've just got a
multiple choice answer
for reading we have to read this passage
here
and then answer questions about it in
the passage there's a part where
a teacher is telling her students about
a trip that she went on
and this is described from the point of
view of one of her students
question 10 asks which sentence is the
best evidence
that the students are baffled by the
teacher's story
and can you guess what we saw from the
train miss spivvy asked
we could not camels she said
we saw a whole caravan of camels
she looked around the room waiting for
us to be amazed and delighted at the
thought
i thought that last sentence was the
answer
but i got it wrong it's actually the
sentence that comes next
we all hung there for a minute thinking
hard until mavis davis spoke up
so that's the reading section let's have
a look at the writing one
you've also got a passage to read but
then it's marked with little numbers for
each question
where it will ask you if there's a
better way to say what is underlined
with the math section at least it
doesn't seem impossible
that if you kept trying you might be
able to get close to a perfect score
and that's the interesting thing is that
you can actually take this test
i believe as many times as you want so
you can keep taking it
until you get a score that you're happy
with it's offered seven times throughout
the year
but the thing with that is that it costs
money to take
it costs around fifty dollars which does
certainly sound
unfair to people who can't afford to
just
keep taking it and then there's the cost
of things like tutors
and other preparation to try and do
better
so the sat might seem kinda easy
and it's probably not good at
distinguishing between the top students
because there are no extremely difficult
problems
the makers of the test claim that the
sat does
assess the literacy and numeracy skills
that a student would need to succeed in
college
and they also claim that the sat
combined with high school grades is a
better indicator of success in college
than high school grades alone but more
and more colleges
are making the sat optional on your
application
and it all points towards a more
holistic approach
to college applications the top schools
are still very competitive
but you need to find other ways to stand
out
rather than just performing well on a
standardized test
this section of the video is sponsored
by data camp
if you're looking for a way to further
stretch your mind
and learn some useful applications of
your skills
then check out data camp it is an online
learning platform that makes it easy to
build the skills for
analyzing data you can learn at your own
pace with
interactive courses and hands-on
exercises
there are over 300 courses that range
from beginner to advanced
for example the python data science
toolbox
has some super useful ideas for
scientists or anyone working with data
and you can do all of the activities
from within your browser
i also love the project where you learn
to draw flowers
using mathematics and the language r
in fact i think i'd like to use some of
these plots in a future video
the first chapter of every course is
free and subscription start at 25
a month there's no credit card required
to sign up
so use my link down in the description
to have a look yourself
thanks data camp and thanks to my
patreon supporters for helping me to
make videos
a special shout out to the patreon cats
of the day
kilgorean and juliet